I bet you'd like to eat Marmite straight
from the jar
sometimes what kind of mood you have to
be in to eat the Marmite straight from
the jar like a lazy mood yeah I want a
taste of the Marmite I can't be asked
and Jason tastes welcome back to grandma
with me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by one of my favorite guests
you always are babe but obviously
there's a very serious message to
Captain Marvel as long a long side the
fan and one of the things that really
stuck out to me when I watched it was
the line was someone says to Bri oh
honey you're gonna give us a smile and
that kind of like everyday sexism that
kind of goes on and still goes on today
what do you do when you experience
everyday sexism like that and how much
does it annoy you and what kind of
journey have you gone on with that would
you say when you think about it and when
I talk to my friends you know the number
of times little things happen throughout
the day that's just they they build up
and they can they can wear you down they
can't offer you knit my traditional way
of dealing with it would just be to just
ignore it and to try not to let it
affect me not to confront it but you
know when it's a different scenario
where you feel safe enough to call
something out of course I'm out or maybe
just a casually sexist comment that
someone's made I think it's important
that we that we do call people out on it
and it's a spectrum of of behaviour
really I don't think there's anything
that we should just be like well that's
okay
all these little things add up and I
mean the patriarchal system is just
rubbish isn't it later I know if you
could give someone some advice he was
struggling to stand up for themselves in
the workplace or they feel like they're
being impressed by everyday sexism like
we were just talking about what kind of
advice would you want to give them I
would just say don't let it wear you
down you have the right to be treated
wherever you work whatever you do
whether you're a doctor your teacher
stacking shelves your pulling pints you
know you deserve you have the right to
work free of harassment hmm
and that's a really
right there all of us deserve your name
do you feel like you're more empowered
than ever to stand up and make your
voice be heard I feel that you know
certainly I have I feel very lucky I
have a platform I know that you know
also that there can be a backlash
against you know people with a platform
speaking out and you're told to stay in
your lane yeah you know stick to acting
and that happens but I just think there
are so many people who don't have a
voice and if there's anything I can do
to help those who have less power than
myself then that's something I have to
at least try and some way to do what's
your mantra when it to pick you up when
you're down don't let the bastards grind
you down I think you just have to keep
on getting up and it's not always gonna
be plain sailing and you're gonna have
moments where you feel [ __ ] but just
pick yourself up dust yourself off have
a drink and yeah carry on
I've just been shopping so much
obviously the Oscars what was like the
nisha Stroman for you in that experience
I was kind of busted with snacks in my
pocket someone sets all must have seen
me kind of thinking snacks out and then
someone else got it on camera and then
oh yeah it had cookies in one pocket
rice crackers in the other I say keep it
real they don't give you dinner at the
Oscars but three and a half hours
straight through yeah you just yeah you
gotta come prepared an obviously with
our awkwafina he's obviously always
bringing the last yeah I must meet you
I've had some wild nights out yeah how
does the craziness compare with the
crazy rich Asians castes or the Captain
Marvel class I've definitely had more
kind of nights out with their crazy
rechange a lot but let's not speak too
soon I may take her yeah why not and you
love a karaoke booth don't you yeah if
I'm drunk enough yeah what would you go
to karaoke song beam with Samuel Jackson
the using my go to is like you know
Coolio gangster's paradise like happy t
I don't know
[Music]
it's not the most starstruck you've got
over some allow Jack said what I had a
moment where I saw Lisa Liu across a
hallway and she came kind of smoke it
and it honestly it went into like
slow-motion yeah and like my jaw just
kind of dropped and I just looked at her
and then blurted out of nowhere I love
you at her and she just kind of waved at
me and kind of you know that the
slightly scared looking horizon yeah for
more videos like this with incredible
guests like Jemma Chan Exhibit A
make sure you subscribe to the glamour
UK channels
[Music]